established by the phoenicians in the
4th century bc
the coastal city of sobrata was used as
a trading post that served as an
outlet for trade from africa it was
later ruled by the new median kingdom of
masanissa
until rome rebuilt it in the second and
third centuries
a.d today from a distance
it looks like it's endured the violence
libya has witnessed for nearly a decade
but close up are signs of the conflict
the conflict in libya between the
internationally recognized government of
national accord or gna
and warlord khalifa haftar's libyan
national army the lna
led to unesco to put sabrata and four
others on its list
of endangered world heritage sites
sobrata was controlled by forces loyal
to hafter
during his failed military campaign to
capture the capital
but the tripoli-based government retook
the city in april
unfortunately the city of sabrato has
seen several armed conflicts in the last
decade the ruins were hit during the
fighting
but thank god there was only minor
damage to the theater
but now sobrata's crown jewel a 5 000
seat theater
has survived and stands three stories
tall
built by the romans nearly two thousand
years ago
it's a testament to the history and
culture this country on the southern
shores of the mediterranean
has officials here say thousands of
foreign tourists used to come and visit
but the years-long conflict and
political divisions have had a
devastating impact
on the tourism sector and of course
there's also the pandemic for now
besides a few local families
heritage sites like this remain for the
most part abandoned
but some still come anew
we live in tripoli with covet 19 we're
all a bit depressed
so i brought my kids here to see the
history of their country and to get some
fresh air
the lack of attention and funding by
authorities
is clear we all hope the fighting will
end and we can have security and
economic stability in our country
i hope that those in power realize how
important developing our historical
sites are
it could create jobs and give young men
an incentive to leave their
weapons behind with un-facilitated talks
between the rival sides ongoing
many here hope stability will be
achieved however
long that takes and with that a new
lease of life
for libya's historic sites malik trainer
al jazeera sabrata well we can now speak
to mkhitaryan rossler she is the
director of unesco's world heritage
center and she joins us now
from paris mctielda a little bit of
welcome hope there at the end of malik's
report but
speaking at the end of what's been quite
the tumultuous year there's rather a lot
to talk through in terms of threats to
unesco sites
what worries you the most
at the moment we have all of the
cultural sites in libya on unesco's
world heritage list on the danger list
so that means we have a continued
monitoring
and the last meeting we had with the
libyan authorities was actually in early
march
2020 just before we had the lockdown in
in paris and we continued uh via
different
tools and assumed meetings with the
authorities
towards removing them from the danger
list but that means
a lot of efforts from their side there
needs to be coordination especially at
sabrata where the theater was
damaged during the conflicts but i think
there is hope at the end of the tunnel
we got funding there is a undp project
on the site for the rehabilitation
and there is funding also from alif and
from unesco especially
for the management plan and the future
recovery of this property
methyl just taking a bit of a step back
here and looking at threats to sites
around the world i see that
climate change has now taken the spot at
the top of the list of those threats and
we saw those
fires on fraser island just in the last
few weeks how devastating
could this be for other sites around the
world and how soon
we have a lot of impacts of climate
change and that
is also the affecting um affecting sites
in the mediterranean
region with rising waters and
coastal erosion we have seen more fires
both to cultural properties and to
natural sites like you just mentioned in
australia
we have other impacts of climate change
whether it's droughts
or increasing floods which we had in
sudan at mayor
island at other sites so we
with our data we have seen that climate
change is increasingly a threat but
conflicts as you just mentioned
um is ongoing um in the middle east
libya in other areas of the world also
for our natural sites in the congo
well as we speak the world is still
reeling from this curve 19 pandemic and
with the huge economic downturn they've
also clearly been cut backs on what
countries are spending their money on
are there the resources to maintain
sites
i think there should be the resources
there's lots of money when it comes to
nominations for new sites but we would
like to see
more resources for the conservation of
heritage as you just have heard
it's so important for the identity of
people
the parents bring the kids to learn
about the history of their country
and their culture so this is a very
important part
of our joint and shared history around
the world
and if he cannot safeguard world
heritage site what is left on earth
and very lastly matilda i understand
that during this pandemic
smuggling rings have been continuing
their operations despite the decreased
transport that we've seen
has there been an uptick in artifacts
moving around the world
i think it's really a problem also with
the internet there are
sales on the internet of artifacts
sometimes smuggled from world heritage
sites we have seen that also
in syria they come to the market a
couple of years later
immediately on the market and we work
very closely between the world heritage
convention and the
1970 convention on illicit trafficking
to prevent that but there's also
looting going on especially in the
conflict regions where
i think in libya people themselves the
community
prevented looting from some of the
archaeological areas and we are
really grateful for that mrtil rusla
there the director of unesco's world
heritage center speaking to us from
paris
great to have you on mechtel thanks for
being with us here on now to zero
you're welcome